let's go next to our caller from the
6:09
area code 609 who's this where are you
calling from
a fax what man total control a seven one
you got me yes total control of course
alright ah I must be familiar with the
movie too long food but there's first
song they play and where is sorry I'm
late for what was that aware are in the
body who I have no idea what you're
talking about
yeah I found was wondering if you ever
saw the movie or not it's a song that
they play in it basically I want to know
where all the bodies arms we're talking
about hundreds sometimes even thousands
per day allegedly dying from total
control are you there because you're
you're running out my friend I'm
guessing you don't believe the death
toll little we can Scott we can cut to
the chase you don't believe the death
toll right yeah Dave I think the
connections on your end that's kind of
choppy I do have questions about the
death toll how come we can't see that
the body's armed they just simply don't
show a cycle they don't take us inside
the morgue trucks we see we see the
bodies a little time I mean we see the
bank they owe their body is being loaded
into the into the refrigerated trucks no
I see what I see one single body being
rolled into a big empty trailer I see
close-cropped video of the ER floors
it's usually the same video played over
and over again gonna like this day put
it like this I'm a homeless advocate
right and your God alright total control
there you go listen
now there's a ringing nitin goodness
everything everything going wrong
listen total control what we see videos
all the time of the bodies being loaded
up it's horrible it's tragic we've seen
it all over the world
we've seen you know images from Italy of
them having to use churches too I mean
it's it's tragic what's going on and if
your focus now is going to be to argue
that nobody's really dying
I just don't really have that much time
for you we've got bigger fish more
important things going on okay let me go
next to our caller from the two one nine
area code who is calling today from two
one nine hey David it's matt calling
from minneapolis hey Matt what's up yeah
so my question is in regards to the
mental health effects on the coronavirus
lockdown yeah putting a lot of
depression and mental health and mental
health experts are talking about how
suicide rates spiked during the last
recession and I'm wondering if you've
heard or you proposed any way to
mitigate some of these effect whether
it's policy or just kind of mutual
community support I'm not actually very
worried about this I'm worried about it
as well I think it has to be community
support and also we need to see
governor's and the president leading on
this because you know a lot of the
infrastructure that's required takes a
little while to get set up so one thing
that I saw one congressman did was a
congressman set up a phone number people
can basically call if they are you know
struggling emotionally and I guess he
got like a thousand calls or something
like that this is very much needed what
I would like to see is from the
president and governors and public
health officials dr. Burke dr. factory
everybody should be saying a lot of
people are likely not feeling well
because of what's going on emotionally
let's all be in touch make yourself
available to others make sure you tell
others if you're not doing well and you
want to get on the phone or Skype or
whatever I don't know how much more we
can do but I would love to be hearing it
daily in every briefing from a governor
mayor and the president yeah I was
reading on Mother Jones this morning how
some of the mental health aren't they
saw they saw a spike scholarship last
month so it's I'm not surprised it's a
big deal yeah
we've got to deal with it alright my
friend thank you so much
something very screwy I think that there
may be something may be going on with
our phone system from the number of
people that are calling in and maybe the
number of people that are using phones
because of the virus I have no idea
what's going on but we're dealing with
it as best we can